maman c'est le c'est le dernier tableau
restauré qu'on replace Anne-Marie du
pavillon 89 ans propriétaire du château
de Beauregard elle engage avec son époux
il y a 37 ans la restauration de cette
vaste galerie de portrait c'est
aboutissement pour elle un moment de
grâce
les tableaux partaient 12 par 12 etc etc
et chaque fois on a vu la prochaine
petite victoire quand il revenait et ben
maintenant si vous voulez on a fini on
n'a pas fini on a l'impression d'une
résurrection Guy du pavillon
héritier mécène vit dans la proximité
des personnages de cette galerie
327 portraits des témoins muets qui
racontent un pan de l'histoire
c'est l'histoire en fait un
du monde vu par un Français par un
Européen sur près 300 ans et c'est
découpé et c'est d'organiser pareil donc
on va couvrir du premier renne du 1er
dévalois Philippe VI jusqu'à Louis XII
restauratrice et conservatrice pendant
25 ans et elle a travaillé dans
l'intimité de ces personnages un
véritable sacerdoce ce qui est difficile
c'est lorsque se présentait un cas
particulier
avec un état de conservation extrêmement
différent très altéré et qu'il fallait
avant toute chose
préserver l'homogénéité de la galerie la
galerie de portraits du château de
Beauregard n'a pas d'équivalent en
France une vingtaine d'artistes en
participant à sa réalisation
la galerie de portraits du château de
Beauregard et le plus bel exemple encore
en place des galeries de portraits
d'illustre à la mode en France au 16e et
surtout au 17e siècle et qui ont été la
plupart du temps déposé des mantelets
détruites
la galerie des portraits retrouve son
fast de l'époque de Louis XIII